good afternoon CSO at nine how are you
guys doing today
yeah it's the day before Thanksgiving
how are you guys feeling
okay it's got to be uh nice to have a
little bit of a break coming up uh we
have an exciting class today we're going
to be talking about naive Bayes it is
not only one of the things that you will
be implementing on your final assignment
in cs109 but it's going to be our first
machine learning algorithm that we learn
about in cs109 exciting day but it's a
Friday so because it's a Friday I was
going to tell you guys a little bit
story uh and I was going to tell you a
little bit of story of my lovely
daughter so this is my lovely daughter
and I think you guys know I have a
daughter at this point
um
but you know there's so much I can say
about it like wow Parenthood what an
adventure it's been I've learned so much
more in these last year and a half uh
then maybe I learned an entire PhD about
life how people learn uh it's just been
such an exciting time you know how to
teach people boundaries
but there is you know there I I would
love to share something interesting that
we've also gone through uh as parents
that not every parent goes to which is
when very young so she was born as this
crazy experience and then the next two
weeks were like this sleep deprived
Bliss of like this brand new soul in the
world
but then when she was two weeks old we
got some interesting news we found out
at that point that she was born not able
to hear at all which is surprisingly
common about one in a thousand babies
this happens and uh you know there
wasn't a family history so it was a
little bit surprising for us
and again I feel like I immediately
learned a lot it wasn't what we expected
but boy do we learn so much first we
learned sign language we learned about
this whole new wonderful culture that
exists in the US and around the world
um and we learned a little bit about as
a parent not having clear expectations
for the life your child is going to lead
like they're always going to lead
different lives than you than you
designed for them they get to choose uh
we just we're learning a lot about that
a week too but then also an interesting
thing is you know she has these things
called Cochlear implants and you guys
might have heard of those before
um basically she has a microphone and
that microphone goes to a processor the
processor goes to a coil the coil sends
a little signal to a receiver on the
inside of her head that's connected to
her auditory nerve and it stimulates her
auditory nerve so basically it's a
microphone that stimulates directly this
thing in the inner part of the ear
and it's incredible if you didn't know
the biggest breakthrough in this device
happened here at Stanford actually in
the ee department they figured out a
whole bunch of key ideas to make this
possible in humans and now she hears so
well now it's such a hard story to tell
because I was so ready to embrace not
hearing like signing was the coolest
thing and I was really excited for that
Journey too but now it looks like our
journey has hearing and talking and
dancing in fact every day starts with a
dance party at 6am but you know I must
say that's like one of the things that
I'm very thankful for so going into
Thanksgiving I'm just so thankful to
have this wonderful soul in my life
who's taught me so many things I am also
thankful for the people who worked hard
in Technologies to give her access to
this one facet of life that I have
enjoyed and you know also thankful for
all the dance parties and the hugs so
that's my Friday story for getting us
started
bring us back into cs109
we are having this wonderful Capstone
experience in cs109 where we are
building up towards learning some of the
fundamental algorithms that are
currently changing the landscape of
computer science and artificial
intelligence uh we will be working up
towards deep learning AKA neural
networks to get there we are going to
start learning some algorithms on
computer science and we've done a lot of
work we've built a strong foundation of
the core theory that you need to know
and now it's time to celebrate use that
core Theory to learn the algorithms that
are powering the technologies that you
hear so much about and today is going to
be that first so exciting days and we're
going to pick off one of these two
critical AI algorithms called naive
Bayes
now that we're getting to machine
learning I thought it'd be helpful to
just give you a picture of how machine
learning fits into the world of
probabilistic models a lot of times we
think of machine learning as being a
probabilistic model
you'll imagine getting some inputs and
then your probabilistic model will have
some parameters and based on those
parameters it will make a prediction and
it'll often do so probabilistically
and these parameters are just like all
the parameters we've seen in parameter
estimation really you should still think
about them as sliders and if you had the
perfect settings for these sliders you'd
have a good probabilistic model that
could do this input output prediction
quite well
parameter estimation is that art form of
setting sliders and that art form
setting slider is going to be the core
theoretical basis for making good
probabilistic models and we really have
two great ideas for how you could set
those sliders the first great idea is
maximum likelihood estimation you're
going to choose the slider values that
make data in a training data set look as
likely as possible and you work through
some of the math that means we're going
to set our sliders using this beautiful
little equation
that's only one perspective and on
Wednesday's class we saw a totally
different perspective and the totally
different perspective was instead of
choosing the sliders values that make
the data look as likely as possible
we're going to choose the most likely
slider values given the data that we've
seen
and they're both defensible people use
both of them they have just one big
difference when you get to the final
equation
in mle
we're just going to have the log of the
likelihood and we're going to be
choosing the parameters that maximize
this
in map that's the fancy version for the
Bayesian idea of choosing the most
likely parameters you have basically the
same equation but you now are also going
to have a term that's related to you How
likely you thought the parameter value
was to take on its current value
before you saw any data a prior
so you have a Bayesian prior and it's
just like the prior uh in any of your
Bayes equations that you've seen before
and you'll have a term for that prior
and the rest is exactly the same
and so realistically these aren't all
that different
and the biggest 10 out of 10 takeaway is
you now have tools that could allow you
to take data and any probabilistic model
and choose good values for parameters
important notation though that we're
going to see a lot is even though
there's always random variables like for
example in this map equation there
should be a random variable for the
parameters there should be a random
variable for the first data point there
should be a random variable for the
nthaded point and realistically the
probabilistic statement should be
talking about equalities of the random
variables taking on specific values it's
too much to write nobody writes out the
full expression instead people will
often write that same expression using
shorthand like before below or you say
How likely are the parameters given the
data points it implies that there is a
random variable for each of these
non-random observed variables so like X1
that's the observed X1 and it's implied
that we're talking about the event of
the random variable X1 taking on that
value I don't want to confuse anyone on
notation certainly in lots of other
probability classes they'll just show
you this and work with it and people
will just be like okay okay great it's
the likelihood of the parameters given
the data
if you want to get really really
specific this is the slide that you
could use for making sure you're
understanding the notation
in this review I did want to just give
you another perspective on map and I
wanted to combine it with what we
learned about with betas so in a beta
distribution you're estimating a single
parameter which is the P of a Bernoulli
or a binomial and where you're
estimating that P of binomial after
you've seen data and after you've
Incorporated prior you calculate what we
call the posterior beta
and beta distributions story ended there
maximum a posterior if you are
estimating that particular parameter
would then take this posterior and it's
going to choose whichever argument
maximizes the likelihood of the
parameter
that's also called the mode so the mode
is the value that is most likely
okay I'm almost done with review and
maybe if there is just one thing to
really focus on in this review it would
be this takeaway about map for Bernoulli
so when we learned about betas we said
if you're estimating the P of a
Bernoulli or a binomial same thing
you can imagine that before you see
anything you could have your belief in
the probability expressed as a beta then
you see some data and you end up with
what we call the posterior belief your
belief after data and that was a beta as
well
and if you took the mode of that beta
then you get the map prediction which is
given by this little formula
it leaves this question for the user
which is what was your prior belief can
I just give you the prior belief that I
always use if I don't have any other
reason to choose a different prior
I use a particular prior which is a beta
2 2. that's imagining one imaginary
success and one imaginary failure before
I see anything and with this particular
prior you end up with this particular
posterior and the map estimate is just a
simple equation so
how many successes did you see in your
data divide the add one to that and
divide that by how many successes plus
how many failures plus two and it's just
a very very very reasonable estimate
this particular prior has a fancy name
called LaPlace prior and LaPlace prior
is just a fancy way of saying one
imaginary success and one's imaginary
failure before you get going yes
question yeah
yeah particular reason why you click two
two instead of one one yeah because of
the beta oh my gosh like if somebody
says beta 2 2
so a beta 2 2
means that Alpha equals two do you
remember what Alpha was it was number of
successes plus one so two two means one
imagine success one imagine failure if
you had beta 1 1
that's zero imagine successes zero
imagine failures the LaPlace actually
has a really good intuition for why you
don't want it
or sorry why you would want the LaPlace
you could never end up with a
probability of zero or a probability of
one
and for some reason it's like no matter
what I'm estimating whenever I'm messing
in probability I never want to think
it's impossible and zero or one can
represent different versions of
impossible but because of that LaPlace
has that nice property it's the least
assumption you can make guaranteeing
yield you'll never get a zero so maybe
you get never going to divide by zero in
your equation
okay good good good question
so yes
what
is
it again
so map at its core is a philosophy is a
philosophy for how to estimate
parameters in general
if you applied that philosophy to
estimating the parameter p in a binomial
you would end up with the beta
and you would end up with not just the
beta but you would end up with this
posterior
that's assuming a prior but with this
prior and the map philosophy applied to
the Bernoulli you get this posterior
yeah and map they're so related map will
just choose one number whereas the beta
represents a whole belief distribution
but they're so related because they're
both doing the exact same Bayesian thing
good question
okay so and big picture philosophically
we have two ways of setting parameters
and both of them give us numbers for
every parameter they don't give us
distributions they actually give a cold
hard number for every single parameter
they're supposed to estimate
okay and that's what we've got for
review
shall we jump into it let's see some
machine learning
so we've got our last estimator
and it's time to start thinking about
machine learning let me introduce you to
the tasks you are going to be able to do
on your final problem set on your final
problem set you're going to write two
machine learning algorithms and those
two machine learning algorithms can all
do tasks that will apply to these
different data sets
all the tasks are going to have training
data and the training data is going to
have both inputs and outputs I'll talk
about that a little bit more this is how
I could introduce it
ah sorry these aren't updating fast
sorry I could introduce it with those
equations but let's come back to these
equations and let me explain to you what
these equations are saying
let's imagine your task is you have some
input movies and whether or not users
like them and you want to predict if the
user will like a particular output movie
does that sound like a reasonable task
for every single user you'll be given a
whole bunch of training data and in that
training data you'll give be given
historical users
and for every historical user you'll be
told what movies did they like
and you'll be told the truth about
whether or not they like the output
movie we think about this as a tuple a
combination of the input things that you
would use for your prediction and the
true label of whether or not for this
historical example the person actually
did like the movie
and I'm going to give you a whole bunch
of these and your machine learning task
is to build a little system that could
take the inputs and predict the output
so
um let's be clear the inputs in this
case are all these movies and whether or
not the user liked them and the output
is whether or not the user liked a
particular Target movie in this case
it's Miss Congeniality
um
now a little bit about notation
notice how our inputs are x's and the
thing we're trying to predict is y I
will always be consistent about that
notice this superscript I that means the
ith person in our training example and
there's a very specific reason why we
use superscript for I and not subscript
for I and we'll use this notation in 229
they'll use this notation 221 they'll
use this notation
is because you see this x it's a little
bit weightier than the Y
it's bold and does anyone know why you
would bold a random variable or a
variable in general
yeah
it's a vector it's a vector why is it a
vector because Vector is mathematics for
a list and it's a list of numbers it's
not just one number the X itself has a
whole bunch of numbers in it because of
that when we're writing it you'll
sometimes see it bold
and there's just one other thing I'd
like to say about that Vector notation
which is
since x i is a list you may want to talk
about a particular element in that list
and this is what the notation looks like
and I'm giving you the full professional
version so that in later classes you'll
be able to follow along using the exact
same notation
but if you want to talk about this
particular value
well it's from the ice user
and this could be the J uh the jth value
in this particular case it's user number
two
and this is movie number m
and because we use the superscript it's
easy to differentiate between the
particular training data point we're on
versus if you want to talk about a
particular location within the list
which is the inputs
notation can be so complicated please
what's confusing about this
yeah
so if we were to apply to this case
rule are we on this is row two and then
the sub
ject exactly
exactly and um hey notice this computer
science is like to be zero index and
mathematicians like to be one index is
cause all sorts of bugs everywhere but
just know that
by one index I mean they often think
about user one user two
in notation
okay great so we've got some notation
and the beautiful thing that we're going
to do is we're going to talk about a lot
of different interesting tasks you might
do that all have a very similar format
another task you might care about is
we're going to look at different regions
of Interest that's what Roi stands for
in someone's heart and based on whether
or not we see abnormalities in those
regions of Interest we're going to
predict if they have a healthy heart or
not
so again this follows the exactly the
same format if I talk about input so X
from the first person and the second
value within that list I might be
talking about this particular number
which is a one
so if I talk about this whole second
person this whole second person has two
things they have all their inputs the
regions of interest from which we'll
make our prediction and the output
you're told whether or not this person
had a healthy heart
to be clear the interesting thing about
this is going to be based on this
training data you make a machine so that
if someone doesn't tell you whether or
not somebody has a healthy heart you can
predict it so you're going to build a
machine that can take inputs and make a
prediction about the output
yeah
um so just based on these two examples
it seems like everything is quite
binaries and it's just like a true or
false for both the inputs and the
outputs yes so if we were to make it um
not binary so for example for the movies
there was like some sort of rating that
they could yeah how much more
complicated would it be you know it's a
good question not that much more common
so the question was hey Chris I noticed
that everything's binary and you're
astute everything is binary I'm going to
keep it binary because I want to explain
all the theory kind of keeping things as
simple as possible and then your
question was if you want to break that
assumption how much more complicated
will it be well once you see the
algorithms you'll realize not that much
more complicated though it is so helpful
to understand these algorithms just
thinking about the simplest case which
is binary yes Roi images that are going
in are you just looking if like that
feature is present on the heart and how
does that actually work so I this is a
real data set from real people's hearts
and what doctors would do is um there'd
be different Specialists who could look
at different regions and say whether or
not it was healthy or you know whether
or not they saw something and no
specialist was able to predict healthy
Hearts but if you took all the
Specialists together and their
perspective on each region it turns out
that people were able to make much
better predictions about healthy hearts
just measuring whether the hearts
overall or healthy it's not like given a
new heart and that's casting and that's
healthy yeah so but but once you build
this machine you can imagine a new
person comes in doctors look at each of
the region of Interest we put those
numbers those ones and zeros into the
machine and it says this person's got an
unhealthy heart we need to go look
further into it
yes great question
um a little bit more annotation you know
just to make sure we're following along
if I talk about X2 that's the input for
the second person
and if I talk about Y2 that's the thing
we're trying to predict
and it's the label that we're given in
the second training example
okay and then another data set was
ancestry classifier so some companies
can look at DNA and they can predict our
ancestry and the sorts of data they have
is whether or not there's a change at a
different particular nucleotide location
we don't have to worry too much about
that but you'll get be given M different
nucleotide locations and for each user
you'll say whether or not they have a
change at that location and then you'll
have an output of particular ancestry
that you might want to predict
so the question that was asked earlier
everything I showed you was binary and
certainly there's lots of algorithms
that break this you could have
continuous values you could have
discrete values you could mix continuous
n binaries you could have predict things
that are non-binary there's lots of cool
extensions of this but first understand
the core with binary and then it'll be
easy to talk about these extensions
so bringing all together this is how the
problems formulated I'm going to give
you a bunch of training data and from
that training data your job is to build
a classifying machine a machine that can
take in an input and predict an output
every training data is an input output
pair so we call it labeled because it's
like I gave you the input and I label
whether or not it's a one or a zero and
I give you n of these
we talk about how many features your
training data has by looking at any
input and saying how long was that list
how big was that vector and that's how
many features we say your training data
set has
okay
um
machine learning is this process of
taking training data and learning
parameters for a probabilistic model and
it's ubiquitous this is one particular
version of machine learning that we call
classification and we call it
classification because you're predicting
a one or a zero you're predicting the Y
and since the Y is like one of a small
set of classes that's where we get this
name classification there is other
versions of machine learning maybe
you're predicting continuous numbers
maybe you're predicting actions there
are other versions but classification is
the heart and soul and where it all
starts
one metaphor I have for this task you
are given is you're making the Harry
Potter Sorting Hat and I love to think
about this like everybody is like
curious about this Harry Potter Sorting
Hat what would be like to see it and
Stanford not only do we get to think
about it but we get to learn you know
what could possibly go into making your
own Sorting Hat
this classification algorithm that we're
going to you know use the Sorting Hat as
a little metaphor for you can imagine it
looks at some input so it gets this list
of features zeros and ones and its job
is to predict a label a one or a zero
are you guys following along the task
ask questions if there's anything
confusing certainly worth clarifying
before we jump into how are we going to
solve this
yeah certainly is how we're going to
start by solve this okay
so we've got these three different
problems let's jump into one of them the
Netflix one and let's think about this a
little bit
so
I've got a very simple version of this
problem my version for you is that for
every user there's only one movie in the
inputs that we're going to look at
Independence Day and the output is going
to be predicting if somebody likes Life
is Beautiful
so every single value in our feature
it's a zero one to be clear every single
value in our predictions either a zero
one one means they will like the movie
Zero means they won't
and I'm going to gently start us how
could we build a machine learning
algorithm to do this task if you only
had one feature input
and I have an algorithm for you it is
called Brute Bayes classifier and no one
ever uses this algorithm but my promise
for you is this is easier to understand
and if you understand this and you see
why it breaks then understanding naive
Bayes will make a lot of sense so you
guys want to hear my total hackie
algorithm
here's my hacky algorithm we are going
to build this machine it's going to be a
probabilistic machine learning machine
and it's going to take in inputs whether
or not somebody likes Independence Day
and it's going to predict an output
whether or not they like life is
beautiful
now in general the input will be more
than one number but originally this
input is just going to be a single one
or a zero
what I'm going to put into my machine
is I'm going to have a little function
which calculates How likely is it that
the output is a one given the inputs I
observe
and if the probability that the output
is 1
given the inputs I observe is high
enough then I'll predict a 1.
and particularly
I might do this
if I could say
put a zero into this
and if I put a 0 into this and it says
the probability that y equals zero given
the inputs I observe is 0.62 then maybe
I should be predicting a zero does that
make sense I'm just going to figure out
the probability of the output given the
input straightforward right seems like a
reasonable thing to do you gave me an
input value I calculate the probability
of the output and if the probability
output being zero is greater than 0.5 I
predict zero otherwise I predict one
now you know hopefully if I put in a
zero and I got 0.62 then if I put Y in
as one the probability that y takes on
the value 1 will be whatever makes those
two things add up to one making sense
yeah So when you say outfit does that
mean significantly one or zero or any
output yeah this whole machine learning
algorithm has to give back a one or a
zero one meaning you think they're gonna
like the movie Zero mean you think they
won't so classification you don't have
to give me anything other than a one or
a zero
but the probability
yeah I'm just
to get to the answer if the probability
of y equals one is less than 0.5 then I
predict zero so it's a step towards my
final answer which will be a one or zero
very good question
okay
now to put this a little bit
mathematically
one way of saying this is I'm going to
choose a zero if the probability that y
equals zero given X is greater then if
you put a 1 in for this so if you put it
in a one for probably y equals one given
X if that's larger than if you put a 0
in for this y then we're going to be
predicting one so just in some notation
I'm just going to say it's the ARG Max
over my choice of y's whichever one is
larger for the probability of that value
given X
so
here's how I want to make my prediction
it's either going to be a zero one and
it's going to be which everyone makes
this probability large
so
what just be clear why hat is gonna be a
prediction will they like life is
beautiful and X is going to be whether
or not they liked Independence Day
and I call this Brute Force Base because
it turns out maybe estimating this
probability is a little hard so I'm
going to use some Bayes theorem
just to be clear if y equals one that
means they like life equals Life is
Beautiful
so I'm gonna use some Bayes theorem here
I'm going to say okay this is the same
as if I took that term and I replaced it
with Bayes theorem the probability of x
given y times probably of Y divided by
probably of x
beautiful thing about ARG Max is that
ARG Max doesn't care about constants so
this normalization constant on the
bottom it's a constant it doesn't change
as y changes therefore it doesn't affect
whichever 0 1 is going to be the
argument which maximizes this expression
it goes away fantastic so I haven't done
too much here I've just basically done
I'm going to
do Bayes theorem and I'm going to get
rid of the normalization constant
because normalization constant gets lost
in the arc Max
questions about that
such a weird thing the normalization
constantly why doesn't change as you put
in if y was zero or Y was one it's crazy
to think that the probability of X
doesn't change that's mind-blowing but I
promise you it doesn't change it is a
constant that's why it's got its name
because it's a constant uh it doesn't
affect the ARG Max
I don't really understand why we go from
probability of why giving thanks to our
maps of Hawaii oh yeah because the
output of this little machine isn't
supposed to be a probability the output
of this machine's got to be a zero or a
one
and so the arc Max is just a really
fancy way of saying I'm going to turn
this probability which is a continuous
number between 0 1 I'm going to just
discretize it into either or zero or a
one
that makes sense
yeah if you go back to the machine okay
here's my claim No it should make sense
um the machine doesn't give you back a
probability those machines got to give
you back a zero one so if you can
calculate the probability that y equals
one
you're not done
you have to do the simplest thing if you
figure out the problem that y equals one
like let's say I told you that probably
y equals one is 0.7 what what do you
predict
oh no much easier I just tell you the
at least on your ex I told you that the
probability that y equals one so if I
say the probability that y equals one
given the x that you observed if I tell
you that this number is 0.7
I'm telling you that based on your
inputs
the probability that the output is 1 is
0.7
you have to predict something do you
predict that Y is one or zero
yeah so this gets turned into a
prediction of one
kind of yeah exactly exactly it's like
Arc Max is a fancy way of saying round
it up
now Arc Max is a little bit more elegant
than just saying rounded up the reason
ARG Max is a little bit more elegant
than rounding it up is it's saying well
I'm going to choose whichever one's
bigger y equals zero or y equals one and
the reason it's nicer to put it as an
ARG Max is exactly this part
where you know rounded up wouldn't allow
you to get rid of a normalization
constant whereas ARG Max which is doing
the same thing as rounding it up has
this really nice property that if you
ever have a constant it just doesn't
come into your equation and you don't
have to bother calculating probability
of x
good question does it make sense now
yeah okay fantastically that's critical
if there's something that doesn't make
sense just stopping this is not too much
content in this lecture I just want to
make sure everybody understands it
because you're gonna have to code it up
okay
so here's my Brute Force Base it's just
our warm up to naive Bayes and the
simple idea is I've got a tiny little
probability engine and it's going to
predict one or zero
now in order to do this I'm going to be
able I need to be able to know these
terms
I have to know the probability of y
equals one and probably y equals zero
and I have to know the probability that
x equals 0 given y equals zero they're
probably x equals one given y equals
zero probably x equals zero given y
equals one and probably x equals zero
one given y equals one
so what are the parameters I told you
machine learning you'd have these little
you know probabilistic machine
we'd estimate the parameters and then
using those parameters we could make
predictions where are the parameters
here
and my answer for you is that the
parameters are in these two things that
you have to calculate you know your
Brute Force Base is going to make a
prediction based off these and so you
need to be able to when you're coding
this up you have to say what's the
probability that y equals zero and
what's the probability of y equals one
and then for any value in this
conditional probability table you know
if y equals zero and x equals zero you
need to say what's the probability that
what x equals zero given that y equals
zero so you need one two three four five
six parameters
and if you could estimate all these
parameters from your training data then
you'd have a probabilistic model and you
could make predictions
I'm going to take a moment here now that
I've told you about the parameters and I
want you to talk with a person next to
you and I want you guys to do one of
those like ask the person hey what's
confusing about this and see if you can
generate a good question for me so
what's confusing about this here's my
parameters think about it for for a
second with the person next to you and
then we'll talk about it all together
okay go for it
oh
yeah
okay hopefully there's a good chance to
come up with a good question I took some
I took that moment to write up
there's kind of three critical random
variables here
X
the input movies in this case
Independence Day did they like the input
movies and that will take on some values
why is do they like the target movie and
I just want to point out that Y and Y
hat are slightly different why is do
they like the target movie and why hat
is your prediction for whether or not
they like the target movie and so we do
have slightly different notation for
predictions versus the actual truth
okay questions that came up yes
I could have a lot more data points I
could give you hundreds I could give you
actually this is Netflix I got a million
data points for you no problem so I have
a million data points but you there's
still another question which is like
do you actually need all these
parameters
I could hone in on these two parameters
if I told you that this number was the
probability that y equals zero if you
want to probably y equals one but you
knew the probability that y equals zero
could you figure it out
there's a little bit of redundancy here
we're not going to worry too much about
it but you could have a slightly more
compressed parameter set if you wanted
to but this is the simple algorithm
we're not going to worry about
optimizations
maybe you're representing a single you
for like
ah good question so the X you know on
some level when you train you'll be
given many users and for each user you
could be given many movies in this case
though X is going to be for the ith user
so we're going to talk about
particularly for like this is after
you've trained so a user comes in and
they like list of movies X uh and in
this case the list is just one because
we're doing it for the simple case where
there's only one thing we're basing our
decision off of
exactly you would just for a loop over
this and you'd make your prediction for
each person yes good question yes um
you know what that's a really good
question we're always told their history
you don't have to guess at their history
because I tell you for X's whether or
not they like this movie there's no
guessing involved
why
yeah why okay good good good X is like I
tell you this about the person and you
have to predict this stuff so the x is
the stuff you're told and why is the
stuff you're predicting
ah so you're gonna make a prediction and
we have two things to separate the
guests you made
and what you know whether or not they
actually turn out to like this movie
this is what we call unobserved
yeah you generally don't know if they
like the movie uh and so you just make
your prediction and then maybe in the
future you'll observe if you got it
right okay I just want to be clear about
those two things yes
um could you explain again
yeah each of these is going to be a
probability
and so there's all these different
things like you should know the
probability that X
um whether or not they like Independence
Day given whether or not they like life
is beautiful you should know that
problem and if you know each of these
probabilities then we'll be able to
calculate this expression no matter what
X or Y are if you told me each of these
probabilities so yes we should estimate
those all those probabilities every
Theta will be a probability
if you want to know how we get those
probabilities
yeah yeah on some level counting is a
very good answer
um
and just be clear I'm going to put all
these into a conditional probability
table which says you know condition on
wise value the probability of X taking
on these values and I'm just going to
put it all into one little structure
here
okay there is a question how do you take
your million users and estimate all of
these probabilities and then you just
said it you're like counting what a
reasonable thing to do
um mle says you should just count you
can think of this as a binomial and
you're estimating the probability p and
mle says just count you'll say what's
the fraction of users who like uh this
movie given whether or not they liked
the movie why and if it turns out nobody
did you'll get a probability of zero and
you could end up with a probability of
one if everybody who watched this movie
liked it
so mle says just count figure out you
know what fraction of people who like
movie y also like movie X
map has a different uh opinion
map says just count but since this is a
binomial like we talked about in review
you can add in your imaginary trials for
your beta prior and as I told you the
imaginary number of trials that I like
to use is What's called the LaPlace
prior which is basically you add in one
imaginary trial for each outcome so if y
equals zero I'm going to add one
imaginary trial for x equals zero and
one imaginary trial for x equals one
so you can imagine you're like this here
is a beta P for binomial that I'm
estimating and I can use mle or I can
use map for it
map
or mle they're both very very similar
they're both basically just counting
it's just map adds in one imaginary
trial for each outcome
at this point I've given you a theory
I've told you how we can get training
data and we can estimate the parameters
what I haven't told you is what it
actually looks like to make our
prediction so let's just go through this
let's imagine you've learned all these
probabilities from data you learned all
your parameters here's how you could use
it
a new user shows up and they like
Independence Day so that means that X1
is one
and we can say okay we're going to ARG
Max this
and we're going to Loop over the value y
equals 0 and Y equals one let's start
with y equals zero this expression when
you put in y equals zero and you take
into account that X1 was one becomes
this it becomes probably X1 equals one
given y equals zero times probably y
equals zero
and this is just going to be taking in
two different numbers probably y equals
zero we've got a parameter for that the
probably that x one equals one given y
equals zero we've got a parameter for
that in our conditional probability
table you just multiply those two things
now we should also look into the case
that maybe they do like life is
beautiful so if we set y equals one
we can take what's the problem that y
equals one well you know that parameter
and we can know what's probably that X1
equaled one given that y equals one we
know that parameter uh and so we can
just multiply those two things and we
get a different number
this was
the expression when y equals zero this
was the expression when y equals one
what value of y is the argument that
maximizes you guys can just say it
but say with confidence
yeah fantastic it is in fact one notice
how I don't change X I was told that
they like Independence Day I'm not going
to be messing around with X1 I know it's
a one what I'm trying to guess is y and
so this ARG Max tries the argument y
equals zero it tries the argument y
equals one which everyone had a higher
expression that will be my output so
I'll be predicting in this case that y
equals one they will in fact like like
Vehicles life is beautiful yes
y here but
it should the law like total probability
say that both of those numbers should be
adding up to one
they will not add up to one
why don't they
act so one
that's such an interesting question
you're right they don't like you're
glancing at this is like this is like
less than five and that's point two they
don't add it to one oh my god did we do
our math wrong no everything about this
math was fine
what happened
an idea
I usually don't like independency and if
we did and we usually call the
conditional probabilities and then we
get to one that's a very good guess it's
a very good guess that's not in fact it
but that was a very very good guess
there's another thing that we got rid of
it's your question
is it because we got rid of
it it's because we got rid of the
normalization
this is no longer a probability
If This Were to be the probability that
y equals zero you'd have to divide it by
the normalization constant
similarly if you want this to be the
probability that y equals one you'd have
to divide by the normalization constant
because we got rid of those two numbers
they're no longer true probabilities and
it's no longer the case that this is the
probability that y equals zero and this
is probably y equals one instead these
are the Expressions whichever one's
largest will be our prediction
Yeah question question
we're not trying to predicate this uh X
is always one
life Independence
yeah it was just um you know Bayes
theorem flipped that conditional
so Bayes theorem said it's going to be a
problem like Independence Day given
whether or not they're like why
we actually calculate both terms because
even when it's above 50 percent it
doesn't mean exactly because you know
when you calculate this one in this
point too you're not done because you
didn't do the normalization constant so
you have to do this term and you have to
do both of them otherwise or
alternatively you could go and figure
out what the normalization constant was
but we don't like to do that we like to
avoid the normalization constant
yes so can we use these results in like
the actual probability context
comparatively like saying it's twice as
likely the thing like it then we don't
or do we only say that we predicts that
they don't
at the moment all your job is to say
predict they like it or not but
it turns out you could in fact take
these two numbers and figure out what is
a normalization constant
because remember the normalization
constant will be whatever constant you
know this thing was divided by
if we use the fact that we knew that the
two probably should add up to one and
that they have the same normalization
constant once you have these two numbers
you could backwards compute if you
wanted a probability so yes we could get
more insights but our job is so simple
predict a zero or one for now
okay
but this isn't the real base
but it was just great that was fantastic
there's like nothing wrong with that
theory it was a really good way to make
prediction
are you guys ready for Brute Force Base
m equals two
what's m it's the number of features per
user and by features I mean how many
inputs do you have for user now I've got
two users we're thrown in zootopia so
now you're going to predict whether or
not somebody liked life a beautiful but
not just based on Independence Day also
based on zootopia
and we use the same Theory we're gonna
be like okay I'm going to either predict
a zero one based on which one of these
makes this term the largest the
probability of Y given my inputs seems
like a very nice Theory to start out
with I like it fantastic and then we get
to use base that makes me so happy you
guys know whenever I get to use Bays
like a little warmth in my heart grows
so we're very happy here this is a great
Theory we get to use bays and it you
know leads to this expression and one
thing that makes us so so happy is that
the only thing we don't like about base
is normalization constant but because
there's an ARG Max here we don't even
need to bother with a normalization
constant whatever value this is it won't
change which argument maximizes the
expression
um and therefore we just need to
calculate this this is exactly the same
as when m equals one
but now it's worth recalling that X is a
vector
in this case remember that X will have
two numbers because there's now two
movies that are in our inputs
make a sense
okay so what are you gonna do this is
the joint probability of the liking
movie one and movie two given X and when
you hear a joint you should be like ooh
ooh joints don't those get big they do
get big
well let's look at all our parameters
this doesn't include the parameter for
probability y I'm just looking at all
the parameters you need to be able to
compute this expression
to compute this expression you have to
say if y equals zero What's the joint
probability of any combination of X1 X2
if y equals one what's the joint
but that's not so bad we have eight
parameters for this term you know two
more for this we've only got 10
parameters that's not too bad
and if you want to estimate all of them
you could do that Based on data you
could say you know counting based on
probability that y equals zero I could
count for each of these and come up with
a pretty reasonable estimate
fine not a big issue
Brute Force Base m equals three we're
throwing in a random TV show
and now we have to make our prediction
same Theory starts with that wonderful
place of oh let's just predict which
everyone's most likely given the inputs
then we can use Bayes theorem and
rewrite this and we can get rid of the
normalization constant fun times like
we've always been having and the only
thing that's different now is that X is
a list it will have whether or not they
like movie One whether or not they like
movie two and whether or not they like
movie three and we'll talk about the
probably all three of those given y
so we're going to have to have a
parameter if y equals zero I'm going to
have to know the probability of the
joint assignment of X1 X2 X3 in that
case
so if y equals 0 I couldn't make a
three-dimensional table but if I could I
would have put a three-dimensional table
here at three dimensional table say for
any combination of X1 X2 and X3
I guess that is a three-dimensional
table well okay any column is X1 X2 and
this is for X3 equals zero and this is
X3 equals one
you know there is these eight values to
represent the case for y equals zero and
eight values for the case for y equals
one oh 16 parameters now
that's fine 16 parameter is not a
problem we've got millions of users we
can estimate all 16 of those parameters
just counting
what if m equals 100
well we go back to her a lovely little
Theory and it starts with the
probability that Y is one or zero given
X fantastic we use Bayes theorem
fantastic that makes us happy we get rid
of the normalization constant we do our
little normalization constant is gone
Dance
and then we end up with this final
expression and we're like okay this just
needs us to have a parameter
for the probability of any assignment to
the hundred movies given y
like oh actually Chris oh might be
pretty big there might be quite a lot of
parameters
how many parameters would there be and
one way to ask that question is if y
equals zero how many unique assignments
could you make to X1 X2 X3 X100 because
you'll need a parameter for each unique
assignment
somebody who hasn't said anything yet
today
okay
yes a lot yes because there's so many uh
do you want to get more specific
we can walk through it together
okay X1 what are the values that X1
could take on
exactly one or zero so okay there's two
choices here what are the values that X2
can take on
yeah and no matter what X1 is X2 can
still be one or zero so there's two
choices here two choices here two
choices here and there's two choices for
that hundredth one
oh that's a lot
2 to the power of 100 and that's just
for y equals zero you'll need another
two to 100 for y equals one so it's
actually technically 2 to 101.
that's a lot
oops we have more parameters than number
of atoms in the universe I hate when
that happens that's going to take a lot
to estimate there might be a lot of
people on Netflix but there's not that
many people and now there's Disney plus
so there's like other issues
Big O for number of parameters so if m
is your number of features
and every feature can either take on the
value 0 or 1. this Brute Force Base has
a problem because the number of
parameters will be big O2 to the power
of M and that is just too much
so
even assuming each feature is binary
this is not going to cut it
Brute Force Base you are so kind to us
you tried so hard but you try to use too
much force for what should have been a
more delicate problem
okay a pedagogical pause
think of the fire if there's something
confusing come ask me or if you need to
run to the bathroom go run to bathroom
I'll give you guys two minutes
and um
switch over to music I'm going to try
and play
okay
Okay so
just to bring us back to the plot line
this was going to be so cool we have
this great idea it was going to allow us
to completely uh calculate the whichever
choice of zero one would maximize the
probability of Y given s what a good
good idea it just ran into this problem
that this term here is in fact talking
about the probability of the joint
assignment to x given y
and when computer scientists came across
this problem they're like well that's
exponential that's going to be a huge
problem and in very computer scientist
fashion they're like well let's just
hack it
and they came up with an assumption
assumption that is so wrong it might
shake you to your core but assumption
that is so helpful is going to make this
very very straightforward
they called this assumption the naive
Bayes assumption and here's what the
assumption is
is this is hard to calculate
what if we just assumed that every value
of x I was independent of each other
condition on y
so if you tell me whether or not
somebody likes life is beautiful I'm
going to assume that whether or not they
like every other movie is independent of
each other
now first of all if you make that
assumption it's got this sweet sweet
payoff that this hard term becomes a
product of a bunch of much easier to
think about terms it's a product of
thinking about each movie X on its own
given y you don't have to think about
anything jointly once you assume
Independence so that's the good news
what's the bad news is there any yeah
there kind of is the bad news is that's
not right that's not true at all like
let's say this is whether or not
somebody likes zootopia
uh and then this movie is whether like
zootopia too
like are those truly going to be
independent of each other no whether or
not you like zootopia one very much
changes whether or not you like zootopia
too
now the Assumption says like oh oh but
but if you condition off whether or not
they like life is beautiful then it's
mostly mostly independent and it's just
wrong but it makes the math a really
sweet question
don't we always assume Independence
anyway so why why is it so awful in this
case yes what we assume we've always
been assuming IID samples and to be
clear what that means is if we go back
to our data set
where's my mouse there's my mouse
so if we go back to our data set the IID
sample assumption is saying I assume
user one is independent of user two
or and they come from the same
distribution so you know maybe the data
points can have some relationship
because they're coming from the same
distribution but I assume that they're
independent from one another and
assuming that people are independent is
pretty reasonable everyone's very happy
with that
it's once you start assuming that the
features are independent that it becomes
a little bit like oh that's actually
pretty wrong every assumption is wrong
on some level
but users being independent is a lot
less wrong and something we're much more
happy with and features being
independent feels very very very wrong
that makes sense it's like it's fair to
think about like each person being an
independent pull from the distribution
think about your people in Bhutan we
assume that every pull is an independent
pull from the distribution
and Independence of each pull is a very
reasonable thing so it's a great
question but hopefully I gave some
clarity there okay I'm seeing nine okay
so in parameters in the universe
pedagogical pause naive Bayes Ascension
okay so this is the last great idea and
if you incorporate this great idea you'd
have naive bands so we'll just take a
little bit of time to unroll what this
idea means but just to be clear naive
Bayes is going to use the same correct
mathematics that we've been using this
whole class and then it's going to make
a very wrong assumption that the joint
probability of your inputs given the
thing you're trying to predict is equal
to the product of the probability of
each input feature on its own condition
on y
so remember each x sub I might be a
particular movie so this is the joint
probability of all movies in the inputs
given Y and this is thinking about each
movie on its own and just multiplying
for those of you guys who are a fan of
Bayesian networks there is an implied
Bayesian Network here
the implied Bayesian Network is there is
a random variable for which is whether
or not you like the move the target
movie
and we're going to say that each of the
input movies are random variables and
each of those random variables are
caused by whether or not you'd like
Target movie but they're not affecting
one another
that's what it would look like if you
were to draw it as a Bayesian Network
and particularly this Bayesian Network
tells you the joint probability of
somebody liking the target movie and
liking the input movies it says it's
going to be a probability that you like
the target movie times the probability
that you like the input movies given the
target movie which becomes a big old
product
Wild
and this leads to a naive based
classifier naive base starts exactly the
same way Brute Force Base did
this GX is just a fancy thing people use
when they're talking about your machine
learning algorithm you can ignore it for
now but you can just say the prediction
I make is whatever value01 makes this as
the largest so if y equals one makes
this largest we're going to predict a
one
Bayes theorem allows us to flip this and
because ARG Max gets rid of the
normalizing constant we only have to
think about the numerator
and then if we employ the naive Bayes
assumption this is no longer The Joint
probability of all of the inputs given y
it's the probability of each feature on
its own given y all multiplied together
and then this term is exactly the same
as before
and just to be clear sometimes we're
going to have numerical stability
problems so ARG Max of an expression is
the same as the ARG Max of the log of
expression so a lot of times people will
actually do log probabilities and if you
did log probabilities it would be
whichever value 0 1 makes this
expression the largest
exact same thing as Brute Force Base is
just when you come to calculate the
probability of the inputs given y we're
going to use this naive Bayes assumption
let's break it on down
you still need to do training but
training become much easier you have to
estimate the probability that y equals
one and the probability of y equals zero
and that will just be counting if you
want to know probably y equals one it's
just out of all your training examples
how many had y equals one not that
complicated if you want to estimate the
probably that x i equals one given y
equals zero
then we can just use conditional
probability counting hey take all your
examples where y equals zero how many of
those what fraction also had x i equal
one that's mle mle says you should just
do this Counting
map that really complicated extension
you guys ready to see how map changes
from mle
made a big deal about it
bloop
this is map with a LaPlace smoothing
which sounds so fancy is that the
fanciest way you've ever heard of
somebody say add one to the numerator
and add two to the denominator
anyways it just has this prior belief
that we've seen at least one example of
y equals one and one example of y equals
two therefore it just adds one to your
counting in your numerator and two you
know both for the Y equals one and Y
equals two case to your denominator and
same thing over here you add one to the
numerator and choose the denominator
that's the LaPlace prior so beta 2 2.
we have ways now to estimate all of our
parameters
and
I'd like to take a moment to just show
you how you could use this so let's
imagine a case where X1 denotes like
Star Wars and X2 denotes likes Harry
Potter and now we're going to try and
predict the variable likes Lord of the
Rings yes this is the nerdiest of movie
examples
what are you going to have to estimate
first of all you have to estimate that
probably y equals zero and Y equals one
if this is the number of people who had
y equals zero and this is the probably
number of people who had y equals one
then to estimate these using mle is just
going to be counting it'll be what
fraction had y equals one and what
fraction at y equals zero then we need
to calculate the probability of X1 given
y
and for X1 given y you know we can think
about all the cases where Y is 0 and X1
is zero all the cases where Y is one and
X is zero and if you do mle it'll just
be counting to figure out that you know
um here there's 13 people with y equals
zero
and out of those 10 out of 13 had X1
equals one there's 13 people with y
equals zero of which you know 23 percent
had X1 equals zero
for both of your movies you'll create a
table that's a four by four
and this is going to be true if you had
10 movies you just have 10 tables that
are four by four it's going to scale
very nicely with number of movies cough
cough night based assumption we know
you're doing something wrong but I get
that you're making it easier
so now somebody actually walks in and
they say they like Star Wars but they
don't like Harry Potter and now you have
to predict whether or not they like Lord
of the Rings again we're just going to
be using the Brute Force Base idea it's
just when we get to this term
we're going to use a naive Bayes
assumption which says we're going to
think about each feature on its own
multiplied together
so we need probably that X1 takes on the
value 1. given y
x 2 takes on the value of 0 given Y and
the probability of Y we'll try this both
for y equals zero and Y equals one and
we'll choose whichever one is bigger so
it'll be the ARG Max uh we put in X1 is
1 x 2 equals zero
we try what happens when X Y is zero and
we get this expression
we can look up all those terms multiply
them together get a number
we can think about when y equals one and
then you get okay yes they liked uh
movie one they didn't like movie two and
now we're thinking about the case where
they do like the predictor movie y
equals one and then again it's three
lookups you know for each of these
probabilities we've got a parameter we
can look them up in our tables multiply
them together and we get another number
notice these two numbers don't add up to
one
because we dropped the normalization
constant but it'll still be the case
that whichever argument y equals one or
y equals zero maximize this expression
will be our prediction in this case y
equals one maximize the prediction
so in this case you know probably at y
equals or we'll make the prediction that
y equals one
I mentioned this in words earlier but
it's worth restating there is a
normalization constant there's some
constant we didn't think about here and
that exact same constant existed in the
case for y equals zero
because we know probab equals y equals
one plus probably equal y equals zero
equals should equal one we could solve
for what the constant is and then you
could figure out exactly what's probably
y equals one
but as I said our job isn't to do that
our job is to break zero or one
now that was mle what if we had to do
map
if we have to do map we have to choose a
prior
and what prior better than LaPlace
LaPlace is for every probability P I'm
estimating I mean imagine one example of
one and one example of a zero so if I'm
you know predicting a pi I'm going to
imagine one example of success and one
example failure which is going to mean
you know calculate how many times I
happen divided by how many samples I had
so it's very very similar it's just you
know when you get here instead of
thinking about 13 and 17 we're going to
add an imaginary trial for y equals zero
imagining trial for y equals one and
carry that on for the X's
long story short that's naive Bayes
training ideas is as simple as counting
uh well actually this should be for uh
for a binomial not a multinomial uh
training is just counting
okay A little bit of a fun aside uh if
you ever get an email like this which is
clearly spam if you
look into the metadata especially at
Stanford you'll see something that looks
like this and it's hard to interpret but
at the very end you might see something
that says like 8.0 Bays underscore 99
and then it'll have a tag which says the
Bayesian span probability is 99 to 100
and you might wonder what is Bayes doing
in my mail server
and the answer to that is one of the
first huge applications of naive Bayes
was in spam classification and fun fact
the person who did that was our very own
meron sahami when he was working at
Google or I think this is before he
worked at Google got him a job at Google
and then they implemented it at Google
and you know using naive Bayes they
would try and predict whether or not an
email was spam or not it's a one or a
zero classification problem and even
though spam became more and more
prevalent as they got more and more data
they got better and better at estimating
their parameters they got very good even
using naive Bayes at predicting whether
or not something was spam
um
a source in case you're curious
so
if you want to predict spam emails you
could use this naive Bayes classifier
what you need to do though is you need
to take each email
and particularly in your training emails
you have to take that email and turn
into x's in a y
what are the X's going to be well what
they did is they took in English a
hundred thousand words in English and
they would create their Vector of x to
be how many times did word one occur how
many times did the word to occur or
sometimes just whether or not one word
one was there or at all whether or not
word two is there whether or not word m
was there
so every variable X I was a one or a
zero whether or not that word appeared
in the spam in the email or not
now just be clear m is huge
so they had to make this naive Bayes
assumption if you want to do the spam
classification really quickly for every
single email that came in
this case what's y so if x is the
indication of whether or not every
single word in English is in the email Y
is going to just be simple zero for not
spam one for spam
this is going to be trained you're going
to learn your parameters on historical
data and so what they did is they took a
whole ton of old emails manually decide
if they're a Spam or not and then we use
those historical data to train all of
their parameters
and you could have done this too so if
we flash back 20 years you guys could
have changed the world of spam
classification just using what we
learned in class today
um
and you know it's the exact same thing
fun fact they in fact used map with a
plus estimation and one of the reasons
that they wanted to use map with LaPlace
estimation is in their trained data it
was very believable that there could be
some word that doesn't show up at all
for spam or not spam which could lead to
a probability of zero and a probability
of zero becomes very problematic in
naive Bayes because when you're
multiplying all your probabilities of X
sizes together
so you know naive base has this term
which has the probability of over I
probably of feature I given the true
label
if any single one of these terms ends up
being zero
it Just Hoses the whole thing it's like
crash in the party it's like
yeah something like that anyway so you
don't want to have any of those terms be
zero it's very problematic you lose all
information if a single term is zero and
so actually this LaPlace prior is very
helpful LaPlace part gives you the
guarantee that no probability will
either be zero or one
okay and then classification you know a
new email comes in you would say okay
which words are in this email
you would calculate the naive Bayes
prediction and then you decide is the
spam or not what a fun time and it
basically comes down to this you know
ARG Max over the inputs given y times
the probability of Y apply the naive
Bayes assumption and the naive Bayes
assumption just to remind you is that
this joint probability of your inputs
given y remember there's a hundred
thousand of these can just be thought of
each input on its own given y
okay
okay so Trinity base essay parameters
just of bernoullis and it's just
counting
okay
um
now interesting question you might ask
at this point we've kind of finished the
plot line
we want to do ml woohoo let's do
classification yeah uh oh we can't just
do the Brute Force Base sad times but if
we make the naive Bayes assumption we've
got a whole pipeline we can take a
training data set estimate our
parameters
then we've got a probabilistic model
with parameters which means if we get a
new example we can make a prediction
but there's one step I haven't told you
about
how do we tell if our predictions are
any good
well hopefully they're good because
they're based on data but maybe the Y
hats and the Y's are actually different
quite a lot
what people do is they actually hold out
some data that they call their test set
so you train on some data with spammy
emails and non-spammy emails and we're
going to hold out a special set of data
where we know the answer we know if it's
spam or not
and we use that to quiz the machine
learning model you just built
so you just built a missionary model
I've got a whole quiz to give your
machine learning model I've got all
these emails and I know if they're spam
or not and I'm going to test the machine
learning model I'll give the machine
learning model each email one at a time
and you'll predict spam or not spam and
then I'll see if you're right
and if I take this whole quiz and I give
it to machine learning model we call
that testing and there's a couple of
numbers that people really care about
one is accuracy
what was your raw score on the quiz like
if there was a hundred emails in the
quiz did you get 90 correct that would
be an accuracy of 90. if there was 10
000 you got you know 9 000 correct that
would still be an accuracy of 90 percent
there's two other numbers that people
sometimes care about one is precision
and one is recall
and basically
recall says
how well do you do
at predicting
when
uh when we think about
you actually have uh spam so when
something is spam
how good are you at pulling it out
that's the recall so out of all the quiz
items that were spam how well did you do
so on that particular subset
Precision means hey you told me
something was spam
so take all the quiz items where the the
ml model actually predicted spam and how
well does it do when it predicts spam
and you can think about that as if it
says spam should you trust it and this
is if it really was stem did it find it
uh they're kind of clunky ideas to get
your head around but people do really
care about these and one way of telling
you this is you know
Precision gets close to a hundred
percent really people got really almost
perfect on this measure of the quiz
and recall was pretty high
what does precision mean Precision means
if I say it's spam it is spam
and why might you care about that
because you don't want to take that very
important email and call it spam so
Precision means that when the machine
learning model says it's spam you can
trust it it probably is and recall means
that if this was 100 node spam would end
up in your inbox and if it's less than
that some span will actually make it
into your inbox and at the time that
they were using naive Bayes and Gmail
they were getting really high recall
rates not a hundred percent
um now just to be clear just using words
as features was pretty good but it turns
out if you look at a couple other things
like who was the sender is the email
sign properly all those things were
extra features that they threw in their
naive Bays
there you have it so
in summary you have learned naive Bayes
classification and you will go build it
when you go build it here's what I want
you to know training is just counting
you have to estimate all of these
parameters but it will be just counting
in your trading data set mle is peer
counting but it doesn't take account uh
the fact that maybe you want to imagine
some successes and failures to avoid
probabilities of zero map just adds in a
couple other cases once you've done your
parameter estimation
you can make your prediction by doing
the ARG Max of the probability of Y
times the probability of each x i given
y we will often use logs to avoid
numerical underflow when it comes to
computers and that is the end of the
story and you know what that means
I'm pretty sure this is your last class
which means I'm pretty sure we can start
Thanksgiving break two minutes early
have a fantastic Thanksgiving I'm so
thankful for all of you guys thanks for
working so hard in cs109 have a great
break and see you back when you're done